es gibt wirklich so viele produkte von
so vielen verschiedenen marken und wenn
man mal so danach schaut dann hat man
auch wie viel scheiße ist eigentlich
gibt und ich frage mich wirklich braucht
man das auf diesem planeten
[Musik]
hallo ich bin's wunsch manchmal frage
ich mich was macht das denkt sich diese
kamera jetzt gerade was machst du ja ja
ja es gibt es ja gar nicht hält was geht
ab und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video ich habe mir natürlich euch
wie das gut leute eigentlich wäre ich
schon längst unterwegs gewesen und in
köln weil ich dort eigentlich heute
etwas zu tun haben manchmal ist es aber
so dass dann ganz kurzfristig die person
mit der man etwas machen möchte doch
nicht kann und deswegen bin ich noch
hier aber ich habe jetzt kurzfristig
beschlossen einfach heute dann ein video
zu drehen weil das wäre sonst halt
morgen passiert machen wir schon heute
vor drei oder vier tagen kam er der
zweite part meines neuen formates wo ich
mir irgendwie so ein geldbetrag in die
hand nehme und dann bei der filiale was
kauf und bei der filiale also bei zwei
unterschiedlichen unternehmen sozusagen
die aber in der gleichen branche tätig
sind um dann halt zu schauen so ok
welches ist besser beziehungsweise
günstiger wir haben angefangen mit
polanski das weiß und extrem vergleicht
den ich jetzt auch nicht so wirklich da
rein zähle aber der letzte part waren 50
euro bei aldi racers 50 euro bei edeka
und das war nicht schon wirklich sehr
interessant weil papst und auch in der
video beschreibung und am ende des
videos verlinkt check hier auf jeden
fall auch ab ich habe unter dem letzten
medium kommentar gelesen und zwar hat
dann jemand geschrieben
macht das doch bitte beim nächsten mal
bei rossmann und dm
das problem ist dass sind so leben also
da bin ich wirklich fast nie
ich kenne die natürlich aber ich kenne
mich da nicht aus das heißt ich finde
zum beispiel nicht sagen aber das gibt's
hier
und das gibt es auch bei dm also habe
ich zumindest gedacht ich habe meine
freundin gefragt was ist denn bei beiden
auf jeden fall gibt und sie hat mir so
eine liste aufgestellt und ja wir
vergleichen heute 50 euro bei rossmann
mit 50 euro bei dm
wo gibt es mehr und einsetzen - zum
beispiel habe ich mir sagen
einen plan aufgestellt da habe ich zum
beispiel gesagt okay wenn du jetzt bei
edeka eine marken verkaufs musste auch
bei aldi diese marken verkauft wenn du
von edeka jetzt von einem produkt das
günstigste kaufst musste auch bei alice
günstigste kaufen
und da haben sich ein paar leute
beschwert zu dass das natürlich da nicht
richtig gut verglichen ist deswegen
versuche ich heute wirklich nur die
gleichen marken sachen zu kaufen
mal ne kurze frage eure eltern
telefonieren die auch noch mit so einem
festnetztelefon das ist für mich ja
komplett veraltet irgendwie auf jeden
fall weiß ich noch ergänzen wollte damit
dann niemand am ende sagen kann ok das
produkt von denen ist jetzt zwar teurer
aber ist ja auch viel besser so
darum geht es mir jetzt habe ich schon
nur gelagert wir fahren jetzt hier
erstmal zum rossmann in meiner kleinen
stadt weil hier gibt es den rossmann
dann muss ich dass ich in köln machen
und in köln gehen wir noch zum dm holen
jetzt geht's los ins auto bis gleich
was ich auch schon gedacht habe oder was
ich noch sagen muss wenn ihr die format
idee weiter sehen wollt gibt auf jeden
fall schon mal doch nach oben und
schreibt mir weitere ideen die ihr gerne
sehen würde was ich vergleicht soll in
die kommentare
ich habe man sowas gedacht wie
vielleicht 50 euro beim günstigsten
restaurant was 50 euro bei einem
luxusrestaurant oder so irgendwie in die
richtung könnte man ja auch mal schauen
männer darauf bock habt schaut sie in
die kommentare
eure ideen und jetzt geht's ab so dass
man so weit ich bin mir jetzt noch
eingefallen ich muss auf jeden fall
später auch noch die gucci sorgen
verlosen also da komme ich wieder noch
zu verdi gewonnen hat also ich bin jetzt
ihrem boss man jetzt muss ich mal
schauen was ist so bioprodukte gibt es
wohl hier und auch bei dm habe ich jetzt
mal reingefallen hat genauso wie diese
duft weiß hier keine ahnung das kann
sein dass das die eigenmarke diese
kondomen auswahl gibt es bestimmt bei dm
auch oder ich habe eigentlich vor dass
auch halt später zu verlosen aber die
müsste ich ja dann eigentlich selber bei
ich habe dann gemerkt dass schminke
extrem teuer ist also ich bin schon fast
bei 50 euro und wir haben gerade mal so
einen kleinen korb für mich sieht es
halt so aus wie 20 euro aber ich glaube
das sind schon über 50 leid ich bin ja
wirklich so heftig
im letzten part war es ja schon mega
knapp da habe ich halt einfach so
irgendwas gestellt also irgendwas
rausgesucht und kann man so bei knapp 50
euro aus das waren glaube ich 49 eur 85
oder so und heute war es halt nicht
anders ich dachte mir so hey bist jetzt
schon über 50 euro weil das sieht
und es sind einfach 48 eur 25 kannst du
gleich sehr gerne zeigen so leute ich
bin jetzt hier auf irgendeinem rastplatz
auf dem weg nach köln schon weil ich ja
ich glaube ich habe schon gesagt dass
ich jetzt halt auch nach köln fahre
heute also ich finde das wirklich so
krass dass ich jetzt schon wieder wagt
euch genau an diesen 50 euro dran denn
hier kann man 10 48 eur 26 ich glaube
wir könnten uns erkennen und wir haben
insgesamt so ungefähr 15 sachen gekauft
das gleich echt schwer sein alle diese
15 sachen mdm zu finden weil ich habe
einfach irgendwie das genommen dass
genommen dass genommen und das internet
alles machen was ihm noch kurz sagen
wollte im ersten paar wurden ja die
gucci sorgten verluste blend ihr euch
jemand den gewinner einen herzlichen
glückwunsch du hast meister gucci socken
gewonnen ich wünsche dir damit viel spaß
ich hoffe du fühlt sich jetzt als es
besseres als andere menschen im leben
und ich habe auch nicht wirklich
verrückte story ich weiß ich kann ich
mal kurz erzählen wenn ihr die nicht
hören wollte es geht um die airports die
verluste wurden es gibt einfach 40
sekunden vor
auf jeden fall habe ich ja in dem video
wo ich im apple store und die person
formiert entschieden was ich kaufe sind
ja airport rausgekommen die habe ich
auch verlost und dann habe ich im
letzten partie im vorletzten partie von
haltigen gewinner aufgelöst daraufhin
hat mir ein instagram account mit genau
diesem namen geschrieben und ich solo
stück mal deine adresse dann sage ich
dir die zu und dann habe ich irgendwie
drei vier tage später noch eine mail
bekommen von jemandem der meinte dass er
die person ist die einzig gewonnen hat
allerdings im instagram nahmen einen
fehler gemacht hat das war nicht mit
unterstrich sondern mit punkt oder so
und ich dachte mir so ok entweder eine
person von den verarscht mich jetzt oder
die wollen mich beide verarschen erst
dachte ich so alter wahrscheinlich ist
keiner von denen die personen in den
kommentar geschrieben hat und da darf
ich seine sprache nicht von der eigenen
person gekriegt wo ich dachte okay läuft
hier die meinte sie hat mein video
gesehen wollten auf instagram nach
diesem account suchen der gewonnen hat
und hat dann gemerkt party mal den
gibt's ja gar nicht dann erstelle ich
mit dem mal kurz oder sicherheit einfach
umbenannt und hat mir dann von diesem
account geschrieben und meinte new york
ich wollte einfach mal versuchen
vielleicht jetzt ja geklappt aber ich
will jetzt auch nicht so unfair sein und
halt irgendwas annehmen weil ich habe es
ja eigentlich nicht gewonnen so leid ich
bin ich mittlerweile schon wieder in
köln also
wir haben jetzt irgendwie schon
nachmittags ich habe das video hat
morgen angefangen um euch mal einen
kurzen überblick zu geben dass hier sind
die ganzen sachen die ich bei rossmann
gekauft habe für 48 euro also ich muss
sagen dass ich irgendwie aus wie 20 euro
für mich das ding ist halt nur allein
dieser rasierer kostet neun euro das hat
glaube ich fünf gekostet dass ihr
konzert auch das hier kostet 8 und dann
kommt man halt irgendwie auf die summe
ich hab es erst mal folgendermaßen
gemacht habe die ganzen sachen
fotografiert und versucht jetzt genau
die sachen auch bei der em zu kaufen
falls ich irgendeine sache nicht finden
werde dann werde ich dir einfach
weglassen und das dann auch von der
rechnung von rossmann abziehen so dass
ich meine wirklich genau dann richtig
richtig genaues ergebnis haben okay
nicht anknabbern
let's go übrigens die ganzen sachen also
ich verlost einmal die rossmann tüte und
die dm tüte weil ich kann damit halt
überhaupt nichts anfangen die meisten
davon sind wir wirklich nicht so nah ist
so aber also damit kann man halt dann
auch was anfangen so leute damals davon
ich würde sagen ich filme nicht so viel
mit war das ja auch langweilig für euch
aber schreib deine kommentare was glaubt
ihr wird teurer also eure jetzige
vermutung entweder dm oder rossmann
einfach hashtag dem herrscher grossmann
keinen plan letzter der muss den laden
kommt man rein und irgendwie weil diese
und warum leute ich muss sagen also hier
gibt es so viel von so vielen
verschiedenen marken
ich bin ja eigentlich absolut raus den
fans einfach nicht leichter und jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt
also ich muss sagen für mich selber sind
diese preisvergleiche ultra interessant
also das macht sehr spaß
das einzige was ich sagen muss es gibt
so viele es gibt wirklich so viele
produkte von so vielen verschiedenen
marken und wenn man mal so danach schaut
dann hat man auch diese scheiß es
eigentlich gibt und ich frage mich so
wirklich braucht man das auf diesem
planeten ich habe jetzt genau die
gleichen sachen gekauft ich habe alles
bekommen was wir nicht genau gleich ist
außer drei sachen und das hier hat jetzt
nur 35 euro kostet das heißt ich war
jetzt mal kurz nach hause und schaue
dann wohl der unterschied liegt weil ich
denke mal wir kommen so auf maximal 42
euro und ich hatte eigentlich gedacht
dass die teurer ist als rossmann und
ehrlich zu sagen okay ich bin zurück
zuhause
wer jetzt hier einmal die rossmann
produkt und die habe ich euch ja auch
eben schon gezeigt also das sind
insgesamt 16 stück und haben wir die dm
produkte das sind insgesamt
die einzige sache jetzt halt fehlen sind
einmal diese revolution schminkt
tablette wie auch immer man das nennt
diese biodünger die von der eigenmarke
sind von rost an das habe ich irgendwie
nicht gecheckt ach so dass ich jetzt
erst die haben was dieses bio erzeuger
beide eigenmarken ich dachte dass wir
eigentlich das gleiche
na ja und auch diesen ball ein den habe
ich auch nicht gefunden es wird zwar
kurz auf meine haut kamera und dann
zeige ich euch mal die richtige
differenz also ich habe das natürlich
jetzt schon ausgerechnet weil ich mich
sehr dafür interessiert habe und ich
denke mal es ist für den einen oder
anderen von euch natürlich auch
überraschend soweit also jetzt ist zeit
für das fazit ich bin ich mal gespannt
wann also hier noch mal haben wir 48 eur
26 das war osman und die haben wir 35
eur 45 und wir haben wirklich genau die
gleichen sachen das kann ich versprechen
außerhalb drei sachen die ich nicht
gefunden habe oder dies nicht gar das
heißt sie muss sich jetzt noch hier
drauf agieren und dann kommen wir raus
also ich hab s addiert und wir haben
dann 43 eur 52 also praktisch fünf euro
weniger als bei rossmann für mich schon
krass wenn man bedenkt ist dann wirklich
eigentlich eins zu eins die gleichen
produkte es sind halt nur verschiedene
ketten so ich persönlich hätte auch
gedacht dass der eben sogar teurer ist
hat meine freundin glaube ich auch
gesagt oder nee was hat dich doch mal
geschrieben die hat aufgeschrieben ja
also denke bei rossmann wirst du so 48
50 lassen und bei dm 12 euro mehr also
dms anscheinend günstiger leute also
diese beiden typen die ich jetzt von gm
und von rossmann ich könnte ihnen
natürlich verschenken
ich verließ die einfach wie immer
schreibt einfach ein kommentar mit eurem
instagram namen unter dieses video und
seit abonnent vom kanal dann haut die im
nächsten jahr aus vielleicht kurz doch
für die die sich fragen alex was war
denn da jetzt genau preis nicht der
unterschied zum beispiel dieser rasierer
von venus hat bei rossmann 849 gekostet
und bei dm nur
6 eur 55 und hier kann man sehen es ist
exakt das gleiche produkt ich dachte
schon so dass es vielleicht irgendwelche
specials gibt aber nein beim shampoo
preis ich auch unterschiede und so
weiter keine ahnung das war's mit dem
video schreibfedern für weitere dieser
videos in die kommentare
haut rein auf instagram die alex ii